don't expect to see that Whitney Houston
hologram anytime soon and
video of Christina Aguilera and a
hologram of the late singer performing
leaked online on Thursday the
performance was expected to take place
on the voice but now Pat Houston
Whitney's sister-in-law and executor of
her estate tells et exclusively they
have decided the hologram is not ready
to air quote we were looking to deliver
a groundbreaking duet performance for
the fans of both artists Holograms are
new technology that take time to perfect
and we believe with artists of this
iconic caliber it must be perfect
Whitney's legacy and her devoted fans
deserve perfection last week we were
with Christina and asked her about the
Whitney hologram rumors right now aren't
to secrecy I can't say anything but I'm
very excited about the finale et also
sat down with Pat last year just after
she had started working on the project I
got a couple of things on the burner you
know that are looking quite good right
now so I think the surprise is better